comme chaque matinée d'hiver Nicolas
chaussier prend son tracteur direction
séchant de céréales pour contrôler les
semences face aux menaces de la période
hivernale notamment les mauvaises herbes
ou les insectes ici il y a un vulpin
mais comme on peut le voir on les a
traité à l'automne et le produit agile
la la plante est en train de d'être
détruite pour l'instant l'implantation
des des céréales est excellente donc
nous allons croiser les doigts pour que
la météo soit avec nous et et nous nous
procure le soleil et l'eau qu'il faut
pour mener à bien nos cultures en fait
blé orge colsa cette exploitation
familiale est basée depuis près d'un
siècle au village de Prunet en Yveline à
33 ans Nicolas chai a décidé de
reprendre cette ferme qui s'est installé
le 1er septembre 2016 et souhaite
utiliser son expérience professionnelle
dans sa nouvelle activité j'ai été
boulanger et pâtissier pendant 15 ans
tout en travaillant l'après-midi dit
avec mon père sur l'exploitation pour
lui pour lui donner un coup de main donc
j'ai toujours eu l'amour de de la terre
et de la ferme familiale j'espère
pouvoir me diversifier justement en
comment dire en combinant mon métier
antérieur c'est-à-dire le métier de
boulanger c'est-à-dire valoriser mon blé
en farine et en pain classement de
facture signature de document le travail
administratif est important lors d'une
installation une procédure rendue
compliquée aussi par la conjoncture
agricole les difficultés euh de de prix
des marchés des céréales qui sont qui
sont au plus bas depuis quelques années
ce qui fragilise comment dire notre
notre trésorerie la moisson 2016 qui a
été catastrophique
entachche encore cette trésorerie par
contre c'est vrai que on peut compter
sur sur nos partenaires
d'approvisionnement euh en en semence en
produits phytosanitaires en en engrais
pour nous aider à traverser cette
mauvaise passe quoi et 2016 n'a pas été
favorable à l'installation des jeunes
agriculteurs certains ont décidé de
repousser leur démarche en attendant une
période plus stable pour le secteur
agricolecoup